la función g puede verse como la versión
estirada o comprimida de fx igual al
valor absoluto de x cuál es la ecuación
para ge x a quien resolvemos la gráfica
de fx igual al valor absoluto de x ign x
no sólo se ve estirada o comprimida sino
que está reflejada sobre el eje x como
siempre pausa en el vídeo y traten de
ver si pueden resolver esto por su
cuenta si pueden encontrar la ecuación
para g x
vamos a resolver estos juntos hay un par
de formas en las que podemos resolver
esto una de ellas es reflejar fx y
después tratar de estirarla y comprimir
la o podemos primero comprimir la o
estirarla y después reflejar la vamos a
reflejar la primero digamos que tenemos
una función que luce así luce
exactamente como fx pero reflejada sobre
el eje x así que todos los valores para
una x dada cualquier valor de g que
obtuvimos antes ahora lo obtendremos
pero negativo así que la aie de esta
función va a ser igual al negativo del
valor absoluto de x cualquiera que haya
sido el valor absoluto de x antes ahora
obtendremos su negativo esto no se
acerca a nuestra definición de la
función g x ahora la cuestión es cómo
comprimir o estirar apropiadamente esto
para que coincida con esta gráfica
debemos que es lo que sucede en esta
gráfica verde cuando x es igual a 1 la
función en sí misma es igual
-1 pero si queremos que ésta sea igual a
g vamos a querer que sea igual a menos 4
así que es 4 veces el valor que teníamos
aquí para cierta x al menos para x igual
a 1 que me da algo que es 4 veces el
valor que me da la función verde y esto
no sólo se cumple para las x positivas
sino que también se cumple para las x
negativas aquí pueden ver que cuando x
es igual a menos uno nuestro valor en la
función verde es menos 1 pero el valor
en g es menos 4 así que me da 4 veces el
valor de la función verde así que pueden
ver que para pasar de la función verde a
la función g sólo tengo que multiplicar
por 4 este valor y esto es lo que hace
que se estire hacia abajo esta función
así que podemos decir que x es igual a
este valor multiplicado por 4 es igual a
menos 4 por el valor absoluto de x y
pudimos haber resuelto esto de la otra
forma primero comprimir oeste
ar la gráfica y luego reflejar la si
quitáramos la reflexión de g luciría
algo así y esto de aquí luce como 4
veces fx así que lo podemos escribir
como ye igual a 4 por fx o podemos decir
que es igual a 4 veces el valor absoluto
de x y después tendríamos el signo
negativo en donde sea que tengamos un
valor positivo aquí abajo obtendremos
ese valor pero negativo que hará que
tengamos esta función reflejada y nos
deje de x que es exactamente lo que ya
obtuvimos aquí